test d'orientation informations sur les
études et les métiers échanges avec des
conseillers trouver un métier qui lui
correspond ressemble parfois à un
parcours du combattant il même quand on
pense avoir découvert sa voie certains
s'aperçoivent que cela ne leur
correspond pas c'est le cas de florent
qui souhaitent changer de filière et ea
pb j'ai adhéré à l'université j'ai fait
ma première année
du coup j'ai redoublé et là je décroche
complètement et j'aimerais du comment
réorienter c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
questionner un questionnaire qui le
confirme dans ses choix audiovisuel ou
les sciences pour eva actuellement en
première c'est encore un peu flou une
période qu'elle juge stressante
il y en a qui savent pas du tout quoi
faire et puis enfin on me si des fois
beaucoup trop la pression peut-être pour
savoir ce qu'on veut faire alors que je
pense qu'il ya pas besoin de mettre tant
la pression que ça au bout d'un moment
on va bien trouver sa voie et on va
savoir ce qu'on voudrait faire plus tard
c'est justement pour apaiser les
angoisses des collégiens lycéens mais
aussi de leurs parents que le pôle
jeunesse a organisé cette nuit de
l'orientation un moment voulu convivial
cette année on a mis en place des choses
un peu plus interactive et aussi une
animation escape game qui est ludique et
qui tourne aussi autour du thème des
métiers de l'orientation pour eux aussi
d amorcer le sujet plus rapide et
efficace je dois gérer d'autres rendez
vous de ce type sont organisées
plusieurs fois par an pour venir se
renseigner le pôle jeunesse est ouvert
tous les jours